Okay.
Now let's get to the precondition of the onald
Trump phone call with the Ukrainian president
on uly twenty fifth now I want to explain
this even more clearly than I tried to explain
everything on the show because this is so
important.
We have the whistleblower complaint, which
has been released and it's related to onald
Trump and Joe Biden and kraine.
And the withholding of aid and corruption
and bribery and all of this different stuff.
The focus has become, did onald Trump offer
a quid pro quo during the uly twenty fifth
phone call with the Ukrainian president?
The quid pro quo quo would be, I am not going
to give you wo hundred and fifty million or
our hundred million in military aid unless
and until you smear Joe Biden for me.
Okay.
And what the Trump administration has done
all week pretty successfully is narrow the
conversation, not about the suppression of
whistleblowers, not about all of the lead
up to this.
They've narrowed the conversation to, does
this phone call have irrefutable proof that
Trump threatened to withhold hundreds of millions
of dollars in exchange for kraine smearing
Joe Biden?
And unfortunately it sort of worked because
the Trump ended up putting out that bogus
summary of the call, which is already incriminating,
but it doesn't include an obvious quid pro
quo, although it still seems to include sort
of an implicit ne.
But Republicans are now of course saying nothing
to see here.
See you looked at the phone call, even though
it's a partial a, you know, just a segment,
uh, of, of notes from the phone call and there's
no quid pro quo in that ne call.
Now I've been telling you for days, this is
not how things work.
The phone call would not have been where the
quid pro quo was arranged.
The phone call would've been the culmination
of something we now know about Rudy Giuliani
traveling all over the world, meeting with
Ukrainian officials.
We now know about all of these other elements
to this.
We know Trump is a mob involved.
ew York city real estate guy.
He knows that you don't just get on a call
with no pre negotiation and say, Hey, Ukrainian
president, I'll give you the money if you
smear Joe Biden for me.
That's not how it works.
You have your people set it all up in advance.
So by the time you get on the phone, everything
is already understood and you can speak in
generalities, you can speak in vague terms
and there is now a report from a former advisor
to the Ukrainian president who is saying that
phone call only happened because smearing
Biden had been established in advance as a
precondition of the call.
And this is of course shocking, but not at
all shocking.
This is how things work.
This is how these things are done.
Uh, surgey lush Gensco I believe is the pronunciation,
was an advisor to the Ukrainian president
during the transition period and he explained
that they were trying to get a phone call
between the incoming Ukrainian president and
onald Trump and quote, it was clear that president
Trump will only have communications if we
will discuss the Biden case.
The issue was raised many times.
I know that Ukrainian officials understood
and it genuinely seems like the Ukrainian
president was not even remotely interested
in getting involved in the wenty twenty election
and helping onald Trump to smear Joe Biden.
The other shoes are dropping and they're the
exact style and size shoes that we imagined
were there.
And this tells us that the whole premise of
the phone call, the content of the phone call
takes a back seat.
When you understand that the premise of the
phone call was that there had already been
the precondition that smearing Biden is going
to be discussed, implied, demanded, whatever
the case would be.
Trump had no real interest in speaking to
the Ukrainian president other than to talk
about Joe Biden and the investigation and
the eventual smear that he wanted to take
place of Joe Biden.
And then after the phone call, Trump administration
officials had the records of the call, including
a full transcript and a recording we don't
yet know, moved to a different computer system
or server.
Imagine being the incoming Ukrainian president
and you have Putin on ne side pressuring you
and Trump on the other side to try to pull
you into helping him win reelection in wenty
twenty it is a stunning and incredible state
of affairs that we find ourselves in today.
We have an impeachment inquiry.
We have the whistleblower complaint.
We have news of, uh, the phone call, uh, having
already established as a precondition that
Joe Biden is going to be a topic.
It is incredible that this is politics today.
Uh, and you know, the next wenty four hours
could be even crazier than the last wenty
four, and it's becoming actually difficult
to keep up after the break.
We will talk about the latest from a judge
who says Trump is absolutely impeachable for
what has gone on.
We will also talk about the new polls,
wo of which have lizabeth Warren leading nationally,
ne of which has ndrew yang at ight percent
do we believe any of it that's coming up next,